okay so we are now live so welcome to
the Sixth Doctor sailor philosophy forum
this time we're going to be talking a
lot about not just philosophy but about
education about culture about current
situation of those and where we might be
a shin from now or two we're going to
speculate a bit I have a guest again and
my guest this time is Robert skiff from
the company of claro have to do some
some little full disclosure before this
i am currently developing a class for
auclair know an introduction
existentialism class so i do have a
stake and seeing them them do well and
be well represented but it's it's a
company that that i wanted to connect
with in part because i really like what
they're doing and how they're model is
different from a lot of the other stuff
that's going on in in education online
and brick-and-mortar education so the
first portion of the session as usual is
going to be gas forever skiff and I
talking back and forth about the main
issues and then we have a few questions
already in the Q&A app if you're
watching this live right now you can
participate by asking us questions or
Greg there was a glitch in the matrix
yeah i mean this is this is you know
this is what happens with relying on
educational technology so as I was
saying hopefully it wasn't completely
left out if you're if you're watching
this you can use the QA amp which good
it's still working some flex it if you
leave and then come back in it doesn't
work again once your google is getting
getting better with that so you can ask
questions you can leave comments but for
the for the the first part of the show
it's going to be me and Robert skiff
going back and forth and talking about
some of our thoughts on the current
situation of Education so for for now
let me let Robert skiff introduced
himself and talk a little bit about the
company alone or no and tell you a story
and then I'll oh you know sooner or
later start asking questions um okay
thanks Greg I appreciate the chance to
talk with talk with you and talk with on
all the people who subscribe and to
branch out a little bit um to a wider
audience so my name is Rob skiff I am
the CEO and founder of a planner which
is a new online educational institution
designed to really place the
student-teacher relationship back in the
center of things when we do this by
really redesigning the financial model
that educational institutions have
operated under arm and I'll get to that
in a second first thing is you have to
understand that i'm a teacher i have
taught since i was roughly 23 um my
first job was in South America in
Ecuador and then um next as a co-founder
of a private school in Vermont centered
around teaching basic skills and arm
math science language arts within the
context of the environment so I taught
from 7th to 12th grade there in all
kinds of classes are dealing with the
social science and and
social science computer modeling and had
a great time it was wonderful but I
reached kind of a glass ceiling there
and so I went back to graduate school to
collect the letters to the right side of
my name that seemed to mean so much in
high red today and I got a masters from
the university of vermont in
interdisciplinary studies or I took my
courses in my did my coursework in some
in education but a lot in ecological
design and any kind of you know writing
that I could get ahead get involved in
um while I was doing that when i
finished that i went i said well i think
i'd love to join hi red as a professor
and of course you need a doctor to do
that so i applied for a doctorate in EDD
program and at UVM and you know i'm i'm
from vermont i love it i've worked
overseas this is what i want to raise my
family where my wife and i want to raise
our family where we want to live and so
started the EDD program took a fair
amount of some adjunct jobs at a local
online at a local college that also had
a really great online program and online
learning is a lot of fun i will i
enjoyed it but it also is really i mean
the best way to describe it it's a
little bit debilitating in that when
you're an adjunct your contingent labor
you don't get a chance to control very
much of the course content you don't own
it you're also hired at the whim of the
institution and you fill in what um
other teachers won't do or can't do and
i started 2008 and then I really
realized on through some because I was
involved in some other businesses before
going to going to UVM when 2008 when the
financial crisis hit I took a look at
the student loan bubble and I with a
friend of mine Scott Baker we wrote a
paper called blowing the last bubble on
the which we thought the last bubble was
the high red bubble that was dependent
upon subsidized student loans and was
injecting a lot of subsidy and credit
into the higher head model which was
creating certain inefficiencies yeah
seems to be doing that quite a bit
doesn't know oh yes it did yes we're
very good at doing at the federal
government is really good at creating
bubbles but that's a we'll get to that
you know later I don't want to scare
people off too early um and I we wrote a
paper and I I became increasingly
concerned that if there was a bond
market dislocation in other words if the
bond markets fail and interest rates
suddenly rise what would that do to the
operations in higher ed and if the
political situation change where there
wasn't going to be funding what was
going to happen in terms of of the
economic model for public institutions
all over the country well a lot of our
predictions and you can look at that
paper on academia.edu a lot of our
predictions came kind of truth but what
I couldn't get is any kind of traction
amongst normal I was a lowly graduate
student okay and um nobody really was
interested too much in listening to this
guy from you know a private school and
his friend writing about issues in
higher ed everybody was well you know
things will be fine you know and and so
to make a long story short arm i created
a plano i started a plano as a design
question okay two years ago when I
was working on my dissertation which I'm
still working on it will be finished in
the fall nom and I said what would you
what would it a higher-end institution
look like if you design it from the
ground up and you incentivized faculty
could you create a system where you
could dramatically increase adjunct
faculty salaries or faculty salaries and
dramatically lower the cost for students
all right talk for a minute about why
that was important to you to increase
faculty salaries I mean a lot of people
would say well you know the cheaper it
is the better for the students so the
less you pay the faculty or you know
your that's going to be paying off in
cost-effectiveness across the jury and
productivity and that's a yeah I believe
I believe humans learn best from other
humans and I also believe that we
haven't incentivized great teaching we
don't incentivize it at the higher end
in the higher EDD in the graduate
undergraduate level arm and so I had
some phenomenal teachers as an
undergraduate and the people were paid a
good salary I watched as a graduate
student some very phenomenal teachers
become increasingly concerned about
their job security and not getting paid
very much and then I also had some
teachers in graduate school who were who
were not what they could have been
that's the Politis way to put it in is
the hour and a half goes on you know my
language may change um but that they
there weren't very good teachers and
they were getting paid you know six
figures and the end and I also noticed
and i did some you know some work with
looking at budgets and how many people
how many people teachers were teaching i
also noticed that predominantly the
people who were not getting paid very
much were women okay women adjuncts
especially in the field of education arm
and you know that just to me did you
know it did I don't like that I also
noticed that how long it took to develop
course
and programs in the hoops that had to be
jumped through and that by the time that
some of these programs were developed
the knowledge that they had in them was
absolutely worthless okay it was like
old and ancient and so how could we
design something that was could you
design a series of protocols okay not
calling them policies I'm calling them
protocols guidelines that would
incentivize faculty to be really good
teachers but also incentivize them to
develop really really good programs and
so arm that's important to me for two
reasons one is um ah i like to think and
my students will my students at a player
know and some of the ones that i've had
before will tell you um well hopefully
will tell you that I'm a really good
teacher and I enjoy the back and forth
and the banter and I really enjoy
empowering other people okay I
empowering saan a good word I really
enjoy helping other people to exceed my
ability okay which is not that tough
yeah to become become lifelong learners
which is what we want for our students
we want them to leave our classes and
know how to hit the ground running
themselves and keep on with it right and
and also you know to be able to create
their own business do I want you know
students to be able to have their own
agency to decide what they want to do
with their lives for themselves versus
having an institution or somebody
pigeonhole them yeah so we put in a
track so yeah um and and I think there's
a lot of waste now in higher ed okay
that that I don't think we're really
were really unleashing the power of
humanity okay with our educational
systems I think we could have a whole
lot we could have a whole lot more
innovation a whole lot more progress a
whole lot more access you know there's
also another thing that bothered me on
that I wanted to change with the design
was the whole notion of arm of people
having to come to North America in
Europe to to learn okay the people could
learn the counties that they came from
in addition to the fact that there are a
lot of really smart people
all over the planet that I would like to
take courses with and they don't all
live in North America in Europe okay
there are a lot of people I've
interacted with in China Thailand on
Latin America who are absolutely
brilliant in and they should be able we
should be learning from them on as much
as um as they learn from from us and
stop this sort of you know but sort of
yeah yeah I get that you try not to let
the freak flag fly too quickly yeah well
we using education as an export
commodity for a very long time and you
know sometimes like when I was a student
and undergraduate I remember that the
students who couldn't get into the very
selective state universities in in the
third world would well he also in Japan
as well would come here and you know go
to go to an American school everyone
thought American schools are all great
and so then it could go back usually
they paid quite a lot further degrees so
schools loved having these kind of
programs and people came to see it as
you know one of the problems i think in
education is a lot of times people tend
to see some sort of you know opportunity
to change education to spread it is just
a revenue stream so these administrators
you know they think well these foreign
students they're going to be supplying
us you know with with this opportunity
to you know yes get I don't any yeah
they don't pay in-state tuition so will
a little um they don't pay and say oh I
shouldn't a payout it you know what we
revenue stream but there's but I would
just say if it were just looking at at
students from outside the US as revenue
streams that wouldn't bother me quite so
much as as also the systems of control
that are used in high red to arm to
limit access for four different ideas
different cultures to be able to to add
their voice their agency to the debate
to the two
wealth of knowledge that we have you
know in that we all need to tap into and
they have valuable in humanity so I was
you know I thought we might talk about a
bunch of different issues and then
eventually leading into this but so let
me ask you something that I was going to
sort of back load the conversation with
a player know is this new you know
educational platform and it's got a lot
of cool advantages that we'll talk about
in a while but what I hear you saying is
that one of the things you want to do
with it is create a community of inquiry
it's not just to supply classes you know
for for credit or something like that
you actually want to you don't want to
use that as an engine to do something a
bit bigger yeah um I think starting off
I mean a player no say it stands for
open learning organization okay and it's
called a player no because you can say
it in multiple different language groups
without you know arm without it being
difficult to pronounce so we're already
kind of I'm trying to place it in terms
of that that global be global okay arm
the second the thing that you're talking
about creating a community of inquiry um
I don't you know my dream is a player
knows a tool okay that it's so a a
person doesn't matter their age goes on
and they say they list their ish the
issues in their life okay they list them
they're not told what issues they have
yeah it's the person and they say oh you
know i i'd like to get a raise my i know
my boss is looking for a bookkeeper or
somebody with better bookkeeping skills
so I think what I'll do is I'll take a
course in bookkeeping they take the
course in bookkeeping even go to their
arm they go to their job and they get a
raise okay but in the course of that
they may also stay okay I'm doing
bookkeeping but gosh though though the
quality of water
okay or the or the amount of protein
that I'm able to eat my family is able
to eat isn't that great so hmm maybe I
can go on and I can learn about
ecological design and about you know
aquaculture okay and I can prove so end
and then you know he talks he or she
talks to other groups of people and they
say oh wow here's this this like skill
this place where we can go to get get
these skills that we decide on but then
all of a sudden somebody from that town
who knows a whole lot about
reforestation okay decides wow I could
teach a class in reforestation I have a
master's degree from you know my local
university and I've got a lot of
knowledge in that so i think i'm going
to offer that class up and then you have
capital flowing from the u.s. from maybe
you know places that they can pay the
full boat okay flowing back into that
community wherever it is um and so
you've you you know is it's a tool it's
a tool that can be used by individuals
to define what skills they want to learn
okay and then also use those skills to
solve problems in their communities that
they decide so that's what i mean by the
you know the classic community of
inquiry is that we're not talking about
you know knowledge from the top down
we're not you know we're not talking
World Bank program to solve X okay well
I tend to believe that that individuals
within their own communities can solve
their own problems the paulo ferreira
okay pedagogy of the oppressed or john
dewey um i believe people can solve
their own problems if they have access
to tools rather than then coming up with
a new program and doing it that way you
know to pay consultants to do craziness
okay
yeah well I mean you've probably seen
this consultants are good for one thing
they're they're not from your
organization so suddenly they're endowed
with some you know some real knowledge
that that people from within you
couldn't supply when you met in a
university setting you see people who
actually has something to contribute
getting passed over and lots of
consultants says it's somebody from the
outside then it's no good well it's also
a non sprinkle some I thank you no go
ahead serane but yeah yeah I mean it's
it's it's striking sometimes to see how
in educational settings where the
educators are supposed to be doing
although the brightest ones oftentimes
they're they're not you know they
they're prone to go for easy solutions
or just sort of you know they may be
teaching a class where they're
questioning everything and yet as soon
as I get outside of the classroom it's
it's you know just business as usual and
we've always done things display yeah I
mean I always I owe it sorry I always
remember wrong the advice that one of my
first bosses I would I worked
construction as a day laborer arm in in
Burlington working on some buildings and
with a pick and a shovel and one day arm
the guy who was my boss had me unloading
um lumber and he came by and he said
skiff college boy play-doh don't mean
much now does he and and I laughed and
um you know kept unloading the caught
the the lumber and then a week or so
later he comes back and he goes you know
I've read all all of play-doh and it
does mean something but what I don't
want you to become is one of those smart
guys who knows nothing yeah remember
that and you know it was great advice
and I'll never forget it from Dave snow
um I tend to think that this is again
just from my experience because I grew
up gonna essentially a blue-collar
family and I worked a lot of you know
manual jobs
and sort of entry-level jobs there's
something good about having to spend
some time doing that kind of thing that
provides a grounded for academics that a
lot of you know second generation third
generation academics just they don't
have no pain there writing reflects it
yeah you know yeah um yep hey so what's
let's talk about there's a number of
different issues I wanted to sort of
sound you out on and we can jump from
from one to the next let's talk about
what's right well let's talk about
student loan debt and and I think you're
right there is a bubble and eventually
it's going it's going to burst we can't
sustain this sort of forever and we
can't just keep churning out graduates
who are less likely to get jobs and are
coming out more indebted than another
it's one of those problems though we're
going to look at it as it looks so so
massive and you say well what can we
actually what can we do and it doesn't
look like systematically there's some
one single solution and telling people
will just don't get in debt that doesn't
really work either there's good reasons
why people do in fact go into debt so I
mean what's your take on where we're
going with us and what we want you well
I think there's you're asking kind of
like you're asking three different
questions um the first question is well
how do we get there okay and we got into
this situation with the best of
intentions you know yeah at the
beginning of public at the beginning of
policy a policy does great good okay and
so you know in in the US where you had
the you know the GI Bill and then you
had the stafford loan named after a
Vermont senator okay the stafford loan
system and the pell grants was all about
creating access for people on to
to higher ed okay and those are all
really important things now that higher
ed was supposed to also correspond to
access to higher knowledge okay greater
skills and the skill piece but kind of
every strength eventually becomes a
weakness and so earlier on when people
were getting loans and the loans were
relatively small okay yeah commission
rates were relatively small but the
problem is their feedback loops that get
created okay and the first feedback loop
is armed once you start handing out
loans okay what happened is it is an
indirect subsidy to hire read where they
then don't really have to think about
potentially some of the issues that
they're creating for themselves like the
edifice complex okay the building more
and more buildings and infrastructure
then um you also have people when they
start on this on this path arm of the
loan piece you have the situation where
that's coming up more and more
frequently that when a faculty member
goes to apply for a job they have they
kind of go I want to get paid X and my
loan payment per month is why so I want
you to get I want you to pay me not only
what's going to pay off my loan and I
want you to pay me extra so you see
there's this double feet there's this
reinforcing feedback loop that I've been
debt okay but your faculties in debt I
said well you know I suppose that's good
if you can actually get it but most of
the most of the people that I know that
go on the job market you know they're
happy if they can actually get into the
interviews because you know I remember
when I first started applying when I
came out of graduate school in 2002 and
it was about it in philosophy for a
decent job there might be 300 applicants
for you know less attractive dobbs maybe
it might be as low as 100 applicants now
it's about a five hundred average and
there's a lot of you know
there's not that many positions out
there that's something we can talk about
as well um I think that you're you know
you're right at four schools that
actually have them money if you're
attractive to them you can really try to
cut these sweetheart deals and say you
know you're gonna have to you have to
give me what I need to pay off these
these these loans so it doesn't flight
things that way but I think for the
middle here in the lower tier schools
well they're in the same situation
because um one of the things it was one
of the things as the debt loads and
we're not talking only about student
loans we're talking about mortgages
we're talking about credit card debt if
you want a frightening if you want to
engage in a frightening activity try to
do a survey of the people you work with
and find out what exactly they are
carrying in terms of the card debt or on
their mortgage debt now debt in itself
isn't necessarily a bad thing the
problem is that it limits your choices
yeah okay and it also reinforces um
class those people who are able to move
through the system with a minimal amount
of debt have more agency they have more
choices of what they are able to do
later in life I'm di luar paint making
payments and um that's the big that's
the the sad story of America in the last
you know 30 years in my opinion is that
what we've done is we've we've limited
the arm with the huge amount of debt and
the heat and the low interest rates and
the Federal Reserve given us the you
know subsidy basically through through
low interest keeping the interest rates
artificially low okay they've just
subsidized really horrible practices
yeah um now should people who not should
we make sure that everybody has food
clothing and shelter in this country
absolutely should we make sure that um
people have access to high quality
education as much as they can possibly
as high as they possibly can get
absolutely but what we shouldn't be
doing is armed you know
eating all these subsidies for it for
inefficient in efficiencies and and what
I guess I mean by that is you know we'll
let the freak flag fly I mean you know
the military budget the wars I mean you
know god what could we have done the
banker bailouts we could have you know
the 2008 what's get what blew my mind
away is that with what was given to
JPMorgan goldman sachs and the banks
Reuters would have allowed us to pay off
every single person's mortgage in the
united states that would have been a
better use of funds to generate economic
activity okay and improve society then
what happened ideally yeah i think i'd
agree with you on on that sort of
prediction i probably would i would
probably arrive in it from you know
different premises that i'm guessing
then then you would but i would i would
say yeah when you're putting the when
you're freeing people off at the apt on
lower levels and letting them actually
do something that's going to be more
sustainable than than these let me we'll
come back to the the dead question
something that occurred to me do you
think that the precariousness of a lot
of you know the professor the full-time
people the people who actually have
tenure track jobs as opposed to the
adjuncts the precariousness of their
positions then is is producing a sort of
unwillingness to try out you know new
things in education or kind of reticence
to they just want to keep their heads
down on the kindest the kindest level of
analysis you could say would be that
fear of change okay i am you know like
that i like analysis okay the most
unkind analysis is and this has been i
have heard these you know these
sentiments spoken again and again we
just have to keep it going until we
retire okay let's just
bit let's just keep it going okay and
then we'll get our pension and then they
and then everything you know and then
we're retired and we're out on what they
don't get is the fact that their pension
is directly connected to the health of
their institution well you know so um
yeah so I guess so in it the quick
answer is um I think there's fear of
change I think there's really like the
new skill set that's going to be needed
okay to build up education and in this
internet environment and the
disintermediation that's occurring in
education all the time that skill set is
unfortunately something that that the
that the professorial right now doesn't
um search for right now it's about grant
writing peer-reviewed journal articles
citations and how well you go along and
get along within your institution yeah
now where you want to well pedigree
plays a huge role in yes and and what I
mean what insane it's insane okay and
I'll use this example hi red is the only
industry I know of where you think to
use the analogy just because somebody's
driving a BMW doesn't make them a good
driver it only means that they could
afford the BMW yeah so we rely on these
degrees as branding when when I deal
with you know I've dealt with Ivy League
people I've dealt with people from mom
uh you know community colleges and you
know what it's all over the map of who's
good okay who's really you know able to
produce who's really able to to think
themselves um you know think critically
and right I frankly you know I see a
little at the higher end schools a
little less resiliency and a little less
willingness to take a chance they're so
polished and perfect that you know if
you throw them a curve ball many of them
are just going to crumble arm so anyway
that's my short my short answer
you still there I guess you cut me off
well that's the that's quite all right I
have a very similar experience in
dealing with I lost you there for a
second we just had a connectivity
problem of some sort but we are still
alive yeah well you know whenever you
whenever a bad my likewise um whenever
you badmouth the powers that be
everything that's a little shaky hoon
yeah who knows that wouldn't that be
would may be awful if that was the case
so going back to the to the the deck
issue talked about how we got there
talked about where we are currently what
was the third you said there were three
questions that I was asking what was the
third question that the other thing is
you know what to do I said what phys
year I don't I do I spent a lot of time
okay if I thought the system was going
to be able to reform itself I would have
joined this system I would have kept my
mouth shut I would have played the game
and maybe I would have gotten hired in a
tenure-track position I do not think the
system can be reformed there's going to
be a major change it is it going to be a
collapse um I think many institutions
that are here today the there was a
professor from Harvard arm I shouldn't
be quoting him because it destroys my
point but there's a professor from
Harvard who says it about a third of
this of the college's okay he's not the
only one who said this other people have
but since he went to Hobbit's more valid
yeah um about a third of the colleges
community colleges and and and
institutions may close in the next 10
years oh and I think that's a really
really strong possibility um I think
we're going to see a lot of unrest
arm on the part of students as their
tuition rates go up and and like we've
seen in California Montreal arm you know
in Canada so I think the system is going
to totally is in chaos it's collapsing
now and by personally I think it's very
risky to join that um you know that you
that unfortunately the Titanic is hit
the iceberg okay but rather than just
having the upper classes get into the
lifeboats it's time to maybe tear the
deck apart and build some rafts arm for
everybody else and and we have enough
time where we can where we can do that
but um it's just not going to you know
it's not going to be easy so that's
that's where I see I see chaos for
traditional institutions of higher
education in the US Armed you know in
that's really them the the nation I know
best in the US it's going to be
disastrous overseas there's tremendous
growth yeah the Menace need um but what
they're asking for is they want control
of their educational process on which
they understand yeah absolutely who you
know after dealing with you know pox
americana for 50 years or the Soviet
Union well I'm i think you know you'd
want a little more control and um is so
you've got to you know you've got to
create systems where where they're in
where individuals from those countries
really have much more control and where
their governments have some sort of say
but but the fact is governments
individuals are becoming more and more
empowered and governments in my opinion
are becoming less and less but right now
we're just in this in this battle space
there's a conflict going on and we'll
see you know certain areas are going to
do very well when they embrace I think
I'm you know more openness and other
places are going to do very poorly as
they crank down on on civil liberties
and freedom so let me let me ask another
question on another topic that we were
going to hit on about John's
a lot of you know we've seen this this
vast transition to using an adjunct
labor so that some some colleges the
bulk of the classes are actually taught
by adjuncts or at least people who are
just there for a year teaching full time
if there is this huge shake-up and a lot
of institutions close then it seems like
we're going to have yet even more people
out there wanting to teach but not able
to find any any positions teaching
unless there's something we can eat it
and a lot of things that are being
created about the moose the MOOCs don't
provide anybody really with jobs I mean
it's suppose you could be you know
somebody if you know we'll use Michael
send out because easy it is the movie
guy does his video lectures and then
there's a bunch of hired hands to
basically monitor things but that
doesn't seem like it they would k
particularly well or demand much of
somebody as an educator you're just sort
of administering somebody else's content
so what's going to happen God the them
well first off I mean you you hit the
point you you're raising the right point
in my opinion is that what's the what is
the labor market what does labor do now
okay the institutions higher ed has been
able to do the adjunct piece because it
could get away with it okay yeah most
institutions because for example you had
to go to the classroom okay I mean God
the running around that adjuncts do okay
and the lack of respect that they get
okay really good teachers really good
scholars it just is depressing so as
place and time become less important
okay what you're able to do is as a
teacher you can get the word out so
that's why I plaire no I mean like you
know the more places that get rid of
sort of well how do I put this on all
the adjuncts I talk to love a plane oh
okay now they love it because they are
now back in control of their own destiny
they're not dependent upon the Dean to
throw them a class here there um they
don't get their stuff taken away from
them they can actually start planning
out what their income is going to be you
know next semester and so as these
schools they're going to be I hope they
all come and apply and start developing
classes and teaching at a play no I mean
after all right now there's like a
hundred and thirty-five million people
in some form of higher Edna in the world
now that number maybe I may be a little
off on that number because I can't quite
remember but I could pull it up on that
numbers due to double in the next by
2020 now we're not going to rebuild
we're not going to create a new
infrastructure okay people are going to
be going to classes physical classes to
get access to knowledge they're going to
be using the net and so um why can't we
um why can't people who have something
to teach if we just redesigned stuff and
and make it so that the people who are
actually producing the goods meaning
teachers why can't teachers get benefit
instead of an institution benefiting I'm
you know I just you know you got ya any
way I could so that's where um that's
where I think things are going to go I
the more chaos the better for us um as
long as we can get the word out and
maintain the high quality arm yeah you
know I think they're real I'm happy with
it the real test would be whether other
other companies other institutions like
pick a player and I'll end up coming on
the scene and hiring you know other
people who are ready and want teach i
think you know you you went to the
summary of it
so I have ignorance is the supply of
ignorance on the planet is unlimited ok
so I'm a baby uh yeah and it's getting
better and better um I think I'm I know
that the business model of a planet I
was going to get you know copied I mean
fine you know big deal I mean then it
becomes then it becomes a question of
well how am I able to support the
faculty and what deal am I what deal is
being cut for them I personally think no
one is going to be able to match the
revenue sharing piece ninety percent of
the tuition going to the faculty ten
percent going to a player no okay the
transparency all those things keep
keeping things honest and so you know
good I'm like you know the more and even
the MOOCs have a place and the
traditional institutions of higher
education do but they're not going to
meet the growing market they're just not
going to do it well and that's and
that's where institutions like ours not
companies because you know yes were LLC
but we're a new kind of educational
institution arm and I think that's where
we're going to be able to have our
greatest impact on and then that's the
goal yeah I think perhaps one of the
ways you can you can distinguish between
educational institutions and let's call
it just call them educational companies
would be are they are they concerned
with the public good um what do they put
in place to make sure that they're going
to continue to stay concerned with that
rather than eventually become concerned
with you know how are we going to
monetize this yeah which we're seeing
happen with some of the educational
platforms that are that are out there
right now you know in the new Internet
economy but let's not delude ourselves
into thinking a traditional
not-for-profit institutions of higher
education okay are these institutions
really concerned about the public good
okay yeah are they really concerned
about um about being around and the
whole notion of social justice and you
know I i would i would say that both the
for-profit and the non-for-profit
sectors
um Kenzie has equally bad in terms of
that stuff yeah I wasn't going to divide
it along for-profit and not-for-profit
lines as a matter of fact I would say
that when it comes to traditional
colleges and universities they're
essentially schizophrenic there's large
portions of them and and you know even
some administrators who are conflicted
and they really want to do what's what's
best for the community you know they
then you know then comes the this could
be a great way to make some money you
know we need to look at things just in
terms of what the payoff is and I you
know yeah I think you're right that that
some of the for-profits may actually be
doing better stuff than a lot of the
non-for-profits I like on Henry Jarreau
I wrote a book that came out called um
neoliberal neo-liberal neoliberalism
zhit ACK on higher education and he did
a whole analysis of of sports in higher
ed and he really took his former
employer Penn State to task I mean you
know there's a perfect example of where
sort of the the sports industrial
complex okay and the NCAA okay creating
you know something even worse than
indentured servants for their athletes
yeah okay not getting paid yet NCAA is
making billions i mean come on these
college presidents and their and their
leadership teams have signed off on
supporting this system and and you know
if that's not okay i would say that's
probably the thing about the American
educational system that foreigners find
the most hard to digest the most bizarre
what what is going on with all these
student athletes and you know i'm not
actually I like going to student
athletic things you know I like having
the athletes in my classes in
face-to-face classes because they're
usually pretty disciplined students at
least of the places that I teach
although you know a few is i can tell
you quarterbacks usually make band
students because it's a bottle i'm sure
but yeah
I mean foreigners they look at this and
they're like what are you guys thinking
you know clock now you have clubs for
that sort of thing right or or and and
maybe someone goes to school but they
get paid for it i mean the objections
and it's happening in you know it
happens with graduate students okay they
work these full-time jobs supporting
these professors and they get paid
nothing and yet they kind of get the pat
on the back of well you know you're
engaging an apprenticeship you know and
by me yeah working with me then i will
write you a good letter of
recommendation okay i mean interesting
it find out how much of the you know
what would we call it some of the the
landmark texts in the 20th century at
least in philosophy and sociology and
religious studies history a lot of those
are the product of having you know whole
team's of graduate students just doing a
churning away at the work while the big
professor gets to take credit for it and
you you know you read some of these
texting like how can anyone know that
much while they don't in the list they
have the crowd yeah yeah yeah and it's
it yeah what do you say we take some of
the the questions i see we're getting
more of them let's start our yeah and
again no question Greg I mean I'm not I
don't want to see the questions but no
question is gonna offend me okay nothing
will offend me so womp you know says
richard nixon said sock or to me
somebody might actually rise to the
occasion asked what would possibly
offend you haha start with with this one
from peter von der neer what is the
added value of a player note over let's
say dr. sailors classes on youtube i
don't actually have classes I playlist
or the great courses you can order on
amazon and the great courses you know
essentially dvds right okay so what's
the edit value' okay well right now the
added value is
were we've been approved by the state of
Vermont to offer on courses for credit
courses for transfer credit so if a
person takes a course on a plenum from a
professor on that course may be able to
be transferred to another institution
that's the value added so you can start
to arm we ask that students and you'll
see it on our website we really
basically tell students hey get
permission to transfer this credit
before you pay for the class okay yeah
some what that's the you know because
again we don't want I mean God I'd be
the most incredible hypocrite and people
should go completely after me if I'm I
am increasing student debt and
increasing the problem of people on of
these kind of like empty degrees or
empty courses so we encourage people to
get permission from their Institute from
their Institute before institutions
before they transfer the credit so that
be the value-added right now on the
other value-added in terms of the system
is the ability to vet your professor
before you take the course and the
ability to look at the syllabus and the
skills list the skills that you're going
to be learning in that class before you
take it okay arm so there's a whole lot
more discovery of information on
discovery about the class discovery
about the professor that you're able to
engage in before you decide to pay your
cash to pay your money and invest the
time to take a course um as we um i have
now about you know in various stages
there are about four different arm
degree or certificate programs that are
being developed with the plano once we
hit five and i think they're good enough
i'm going to go to the state of Vermont
and get degree-granting well apply for
degree-granting authority and also um
we're doing that starting the process of
taking a look at getting approved and
accredited in europe in latin america in
a country you know in a couple countries
in latin american we're also going to be
working with the Ministry of Education
in China so as we build more
as we get more different political units
to recognize our degrees um that's going
to increase the value of the course and
eventually we're of course going to go
for regional accreditation arm you
probably with the New England
Association but who knows um you know
it's going to be some you know the more
I I kind of say you know if you want to
be in education Oh get accredited why
not um it's not as if you know those
people are crazy or something they're
trying to create good standards and play
in that world on what do you have to
hide on you shouldn't have anything to
hide and you should be very transparent
your operations and what you're teaching
the students you know this is this is a
question to where I think as a you know
somebody who's developing a class 4a
Claire no I could I could say a bit more
about that so somebody let's say they
watch my my youtube videos on
existentialism I have a playlist and
right now it's got about 40 to 43 videos
and it each is about an hour long what
aren't they getting through those those
videos well they're not getting handouts
they're not getting any sort of
interaction except for you know in
comments they can you know leave a
comment and I try to respond to them but
it's not the sort of interaction that
you actually have dealing with a
professor in a class setting and that's
built into the class there's no real
structure to it you're not going along
with other students studying the same
material you know hitting the texts I
also you know develop lesson sections in
eau claire know for the course that that
we're doing so for instance one of the
texts that we'll look at in the
existentialism glass ceilings Kafka's
the metamorphosis and i've got a lesson
section specifically on alienation in
Kafka's metamorphosis sometimes you know
a student doesn't just need to hear it
or see it and read it they need
other other means sort of like that you
know a whole scaffold of different ways
to go at the same material that's why I
like the plural platform because I can
build all that sort of stuff in that's
just that I pop youtube videos the
YouTube videos are actually just a
supplementary source to the real class
that is going to you know eventually
going to be taught over 12-week periods
going through these is 11 existentialist
thinkers and having um video class
sessions you know where there's real
interaction youtube videos are great I'm
really happy that we're you know I i
I've now passed a million views and
YouTube and there's people worldwide
watching this stuff and saying this is
no this is useful for me my you know I
had a tough time in my class with this
that's great but it's not interactive
what a player to offer yeah I mean is it
to be interactive and struck out often I
couldn't have said it better myself arm
humans learn best from other humans in
small groups you're not you cannot do
that in life okay I I really love the
liberal arts and I do not believe that I
think plato was wrong in Socrates was
wrong in in creating a line between tech
nay ok knowledge of how to do stuff and
the a philosophy I think you know what
you have I think you know I believe in
praxis in both you have to have theory
in practice um but I'm not living in 18
you know in Athens you know during their
time period so they were dealing with
their whole other other other set of
issues oh yeah what we've done today is
um we in high red there's a little bit
of a poo pooing of practice and of the
voc-tech okay and not understanding that
liberal arts I mean it originally was
the arts that make people three now you
can say that was only the slaveholders
and the property owners in Athens but
it's the principle okay that we have to
point
and it's what is going to keep a person
free and today it's if you know a trade
okay like I'm a big proponent of you
know learn a trade if you want to really
be free and be able to have a job okay
well you know get your certificate in
plumbing or in carpentry okay and you
will not lack for a meal because yeah
we'll be able to i will be able to earn
but I've I've hung around with people in
the trades and you know what they know
um extensive sections of Plato or poetry
or art or arm all kinds of different
stuff and so we've kind of in our
society we've we've separated out those
those two pieces and we've got to rejoin
them so liberal arts means making
yourself free and maintaining your
freedom and that is ah both you know
philosophy Chinese philosophy all the
cause of all the big all them as much
knowledge as you can get and also the
trades
looks like looking some connectivity
problems again not sure quite why I can
sue them um did you get the part about
the in-ear me yeah did you get the part
about the play-doh in the trades because
that was probably getting edited out who
knows yeah it's too radical but you guys
heard that part or not yeah that okay
Plato Plato had Aristotle does it a bit
although Aristotle's much better about
bringing these these things together
that's why I can I can teach you know
Aristotle when I when I go and do guest
lectures at the Culinary Institute of
America sometimes because they get it
you know aerosol can teach you something
about being a chef let's let's move on
to another question then let's I know
these came up early to hear so there's
two by Christopher done let's take this
first one will the education from a
plural be considered just as valuable as
other schools since this is an
online-only school so that's a good good
jumping off point I think arm long term
I think yes short term I think no arm
you know we don't have the history of
the you know the IV color ivy-covered
walls and we don't have the name we're
not BMW okay um so the quick answer is
longer term is more people look at at
skills and more people look at the
quality of our classes and the
instructors and as we build the networks
I think it will be looked upon as
equally valid but right now um no I mean
you know we received our approval last
month okay I've got a hundred and now
we've signed contracts with 140 faculty
we've got 87 classes under development
five programs I don't have any you know
I'm developing relationships with star
quote really competent you know people
I'm trying to get you know Bruno Latour
and manuel de londa to teach you know to
teach courses but that's going to be a
little while they're going to be like a
player now um so the
initial group of faculty and students
are going to have to be people who share
our vision and who are sick and tired of
the arm who want to do something new
yeah explorers you might say yea or
where we're just you know who are fed up
um I also don't know you know the US
isn't army the US isn't the be-all
end-all it's not the the center of the
world and so there are other people in
other parts of the world who you know
one I get we get arm hits from you know
Afghanistan we get a few from Iran we
get a few from all kinds of different
places and you know people are hungry
for knowledge and you know everything
works on a smartphone so you know all of
those kinds of things are going to add
up to as we get the word out a really
amazing system and it's going to be
people like you know like Greg it's
going to be people like um Mary faith
sir solely I mean really really good
competent interesting people teaching
courses um it's going to be our group
down in Brazil who um you know will be
developing computer science classes and
Portuguese you know that's you know
they're going to make a play know what
it is it's not going to be you know Rob
skiff or Daniel Daniel Compton or Dan
Kirk I mean it's our network of faculty
we're here to help faculty not faculty
are the treasure of any institution
we're actually going to treat them with
the respect that they deserve yeah i
think if i remember right in our we had
a conversation about this and i used the
example of being kind of like a catalyst
that helps things precipitate out of
Absolution that's what you guys aim to
do is to be the catalyst to allow what's
there actually gel and crystallize let's
take another one by Christopher done
this is a nuts-and-bolts question and
it's can professors make courses that
are on specific authors or works
for example could we have of course just
on vid consigns philosophical
investigations or just uh Marx's capital
that would actually you know a couple
semesters on that probably um if you can
do a certificate they do at home yeah
I'm infinite yeah that that's what
absolutely um I do you what do you want
to sing about them yeah I say absolutely
um if you have if you want to teach just
one book or you want to teach one author
arm you know I think there's a great
potential for a course on empire arm
Commonwealth and multitude by heart and
negri okay that'd be a great that'd be a
great actually you know I could see
three courses on that you know anything
marks I mean you know why the sky's the
limit are you passionate about something
do you are you an expert in that topic
can we find 40 people worldwide who are
interested in that topic absolutely okay
I mean that's probably the key thing can
you know that a player know that's what
gives a player no its edge in relation
to the brick-and-mortar schools can you
find enough people to actually have a
class on something and the answer is
always been yes yeah i mean it's it's uh
the marketing pieces in some ways are
strong well in some ways our strongest
and our weakest part okay yeah because
we're trying to empower faculty also to
go out and you know like the old agoura
in ancient Greece um in Athens which was
you know a place where people stood up
and they started to teach and then
students would come and listen to those
teachers and you know maybe some of
those students would actually support
the support them via donations etc so
but that involved the professor getting
out and spreading the word so for
example Greg you're doing a great job of
that that's really you are kind of the
prototype of the new type of instructor
or professor okay because you're
actually getting out there and mixing it
up
and that's what that's what actually we
need more of because it invigorates the
public sphere and it also um you know we
I really like um you know I I don't
really want okay there are all kinds of
options I'd like to find people who are
experts in their field who want to teach
one or two classes okay a semester or a
year okay because um there's something
wonderful about somebody who actually
knows how to do something teaching the
course okay I mean and and there's
actually something wonderful about it
about a person who has thought deeply
about heart and negri or you know
deleuze or Dewey okay and is applied
that I mean I'm in you know that's in
terms of the philosophy social sciences
there's something wonderful about you
know John Todd in Woods Hole
Massachusetts who is an expert on
ecological design okay and take he's
also working on creating these systems
all over the world needs a great teacher
and making it so that he can you know
supplement his income um and that's what
we're really talking about so please get
us that course proposal on victim Stein
and I very well may take it because
that's another another part of a player
know is that you know i'm sick a honey
boo boo and this sort of you know i'm
sick of this track i mean i'm gonna say
it you know is trashy consumerist
nonsense that that we're surrounding
ourselves in creating you know that
there's great there people producing
amazing art and literature today okay
that we should be reflecting on and
getting involved in I mean I way way
Banksy or someone who wants to teach
about I mean I still when I read
mensches where I read Confucian
philosophy and I and I pull it up and
you know i'm reading about motsu and the
things that they talk about me it's
totally contemporary i read about arm
you know Shakespeare or or or well I
mean good god I mean what's more
relevant than or well today and we have
to get back to
aging in tho in big ideas and important
ideas and realizing that everybody can
do that and any enough enough honey boo
boo enough yeah you know I can I can say
to that in response to chris's question
after i finished the existential ism
class I'm pitching some more classes and
one of them is actually going to be
specifically on Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics yeah and it's going to draw in
you know where the other discussions and
the politics and the rhetoric and the
topics and all these other things come
in with it and I'm excited to do that in
part because I've never gotten I've
gotten to teach his ethics over and over
and over again in in various classes on
ancient philosophy classes or ethics
classes or or you know social political
philosophy classes but I've never
actually been able to just concentrate
on that and you know do the sort of
things that I I like to do as somebody
who's been studying Aristotle for 20
years now you know the plural is me the
chance to be able to do that something
that I wouldn't be able to do except if
I got a job you know some plum job at
some research institution and students
wouldn't be able to take that class
unless they were at that research
institution so it's you know this is
actually opening up huge opportunities
the most um you know it's funny you
mentioned the Nicomachean ethics or the
you know you were pronouncing it
slightly differently than I just did um
as an undergraduate I took a course on
Hume okay and the Maquis and ethics from
a man named Hiroshi Miyagi okay who was
um professor at middlebury college but
he was also i think provost at
university of michigan the guy spoke you
know tons of you know japanese chinese
english german arm and a few others on
you know no way i was ever going to be
able to match his um you know his his
knowledge and the fact that you get
mixed
is of different viewpoints different
backgrounds different philosophies and
then you have the ability to bring them
together in a course I mean that was
probably one of the best courses i have
ever taken on and stuck with me about
Humes concept of benevolence and then
connecting it with um you know the
Chinese concept of dren um which is
again and just wow you know I mean
that's what it's all about searching for
the commonalities the differences on
engaging in things that are outside your
comfort zone and that's a hell of a lot
better than the bachelor and the
Bachelorette not to belabor the point is
that show still on i don't i don't know
it is it is mike that's my kind of dirty
little secret i do every once in a while
enjoy watching you know the the train
wreck of relationships that happen on
that that show I really I was really
surprised there's gonna be a bit of a
digression but I was really surprised I
don't remember what we were watching it
was on it was on network TV and oh it
was survivor hahaha you know I just
assume that that show couldn't go on
forever but apparently it's still tough
yeah how many gimmicks can you get you
important to how many challenges could
there possibly be you know or alliances
or whatever whatever is going on with it
to actually draw eyeballs but apparently
it's still you know still drawing
ratings I keep waiting for American Idol
go finally fold up as well but that'll
probably be here you know another 20
years as well I mean survivor survivors
are great survivors a great show it I
don't like watching it because it brings
back too many too many memories of
interdepartmental politics it easy you
know pull off the island I'm sorry you
don't get tenure your immunity idol is
gone I mean it's the same dynamic it's
sad but you know that's true yeah let's
so let's take another one this is from
this is actually for my wife Andy Shaka
will there be only higher ed courses
offered or will the or will blow those
who currently use platforms like
Linda calm for business and tech skills
Ruby calm for cooking craftsy.com for
craft skills all those sorts of things
find course is offering that kind of ad
hoc construction as well I think the arm
okay ah voc-tech skills and the tech
centers okay that kind of piece arm I
could see maybe a plan on moving there
depends on faculty interest arm cooking
you know I'd like we had apropos I just
got a outline of a proposal this week
from person who's got a great experience
in the hospitality and restaurant
industry talking about you know um that
type of management you know some
management classes and so I could see
that happening I just have to tread
lightly politically okay in terms of the
accreditation pieces um ah did as I told
a group earlier this week the
counter-revolution hasn't yet happened
ok on the wagons have not yet been
circled on we're getting a little bit
now with some of the proposals that
people have to regulate online for
profit educational institutions by you
know making them being much more
transparent which is my opinion great
arm and I don't have a problem with it
but I've been kind of like designing
things and and create you know might and
our team has been creating things to
sort of you know they can you know what
if they want information we can give
them information if they want to you
know so so I would say the short answer
to the question is um potentially yes
but we also don't want to dilute the
notion of of changing the higher Ed's
fear but but there's a possibility it
depends like you know if I get five or
ten instructors who are really
phenomenal and they come up with
proposals I'm not going to prevent them
from being innovative and doing some
really cool stuff we'll just have to
figure out a way to make it work what do
you think
I mean one of the it seems like one of
the obstacles to doing that online first
cannon hands-on compelling like cooking
for example or is it being an
electrician I mean there's some classes
an electrician you can take that that
you don't actually have to do something
that somebody in like take a look at
physically I suppose you know with with
the kinds of things that we have
available through through cameras some
of that could be gotten around it we'd
have to really do a lot of thinking
about how exactly we would measure those
experiential parts of Education well
although all that Greg is going to
change oh and it is going to be able to
do pretty much everything arm remotely I
mean you know I can stick on I had one
professor arm one faculty member who is
developing a course on in ecology and
it's going to be taking their students
on field walks using google glass okay
yeah that would be cool great arm you
know electrician piece that's actually
kind of easy on because again you can
record with the heads up display what's
happening arm that fits in a little bit
to the portfolio what won't and as the
interface has become better and better
there will be more and more things that
will be able to be done what we're
lacking right now is you know the VR is
you know I play computer games because
they any kind of current in terms of
what's going to be available to
everybody in in like every 25 years um
and the VR is so good and so real now
that what we're lacking is really the
interface and the touch on the touch
peace but I see that coming online in
probably you know five to ten years arm
and that will that's another thing
that's going to totally change the face
to face piece uh for example I when I
was first experimenting with online you
know first but when I was
trying to create virtual classrooms on
my students and I it from our Commons um
and this could have only happened at a
school where you know I was the chair
and one of the founders so I could get
away with this we met we had times when
we would meet online in worlds of
warcraft than our characters we were
playing around with being able to
exchange and to learn about um you mean
virtually that makes sense because it's
a better interface than say second life
oh yeah much better um and second life
yeah what second life was just it was a
wonderful first attempt but again they
lost they got so concerned about making
cash that they that they skimped on the
interface when really it's the computer
gaming I mean you know Blizzard does a
phenomenal job arm so those pieces are
going to wheat we haven't even begun
okay right now we've got a great
substitute canvas by instructure is
phenomenal okay it is blowing blackboard
away blackboard I'm sorry your product
it is not very good and it is wicked
expensive yes okay um and you know I
mean they first quoted me uh oh yeah we
can do that for you rob it's going to
cost you one hundred sixty thousand
dollars a year okay thank you i shall
pass on where is much more responsive
and better you know I think canvases
real competition is though is sick I and
and Moodle you know these these free
platforms and you're you're right
canvases is can go toe-to-toe with any
of those I i looked at moodle I was not
um yeah I have to yeah you know I I was
not impressed um it also in terms of you
know running an infrastructure I mean
I'm a teacher okay and I want and I and
our value added is working with faculty
and creating programs okay canvas
supplies the the infrastructure and the
support that allows us to do really good
work forget um you know and and I think
too many businesses
start to concentrate on things that are
not their core competencies okay I mean
again oh yeah yeah and again you know
it's not as if there aren't there isn't
enough um craziness it's sorry the kids
are going slightly nuts downstairs um
it's not as if there's not enough
ignorant be picking of crazy yes yeah
speaking of craziness i heard the kids
yelling but luckily mom is there and
along with some friends to make sure
that you know the cop cars don't show up
so let's take a let's take another
question this is from jakub Steen Madsen
a guy that I know from from Denmark
who's very involved with educational
technology and has a lot of interesting
projects going at any given time he asks
in relation to guy standings concept of
the pregnant precariat class and I'm not
familiar with that is a player no and
similar new open learning trends showing
us the crisis of academics and how they
will eventually be the highest placed
risk job in the future that's that's an
interesting thing to ask well academics
be the highest risk job in the future
okay I'm just going to google for a
second so I make sure that I precariat
class carry a class so one second yeah
but i am not familiar will it sounds
like you know sort of a mash together of
the probability resistance perhaps it
says on Wikipedia wonderful tool the
precariat is a social class form by
people suffering from precarity which is
a condition of existence without
predictability or security affecting
material or psychological welfare as
well as being a member of a proletariat
class of industrial workers who lack
their own means of production and sell
their labor to live um that's almost a
definition of adjuncts yeah yeah um
I think that when I made I all I'll
answer the question this way when I
started to take a look at at getting
that tenure-track job i looked for
historical arm precedence industries
that were undergoing great changes due
to technology um and how they dealt with
it and I came back to joining becoming a
tenured track teacher now as joining
middle management of general motors in
1978 okay yeah and that there were going
to be new forces of global you know the
Japanese were coming into the market the
technology that was being used was not
that was you know not up to snuff and
that while you would think hey you know
getting a tenure-track teaching job is a
risky proposition I mean sorry is a very
secure job what I came to the conclusion
was that it was actually a very
high-risk gamble now if if in higher ed
we start to really create the create the
system where faculty are that what
there's a lot of transparency about what
faculty are doing and you can actually
look at a teacher look at the teachers
courses and classes and see that they're
of high quality I think there instead of
it being the highest risk job of the
future it's going to be a lot less risky
than the tenure track that is dependent
upon an institution that's on shaky
financial grounds but the fact is that
we're in this period right now where I
don't see very many ports of safety yeah
I don't see very many sure bets at all
across across the globe on the
institutions are failing us that
technology is very disruptive on it's
definitely precarious if you're in the
in the developed world and you you're
kind of of that you know the middle up
middle class and you've been you know
relying on government or industries that
are subsidized by the government so i
would say arm it's a risky job but it's
not as risky as arm becoming a
tenure-track professor on today i would
much rather be an adjunct working at a
plane oh well i'm working at a player
known as an adjunct i would much rather
i think my long-term prospects are
higher here as a faculty member than
they are and if i were to get that
tenure-track job at one of the local
community colleges arm or smaller state
schools in the US Europe you have your
own issues that um I can't really
comment on yeah although you know we're
also seeing in Britain the same sort of
crises that we're having here they're
going through it as well a please feel
free to follow up with me if you didn't
find that answer particularly good or
you think I was dodging the issue so
just shoot me an email at skiff at a
Plano calm because I love to talk with
you more about it because I'm not sure I
like a little bit more information on
the precariat class I think it's a great
term yeah you know even tenure-track
professors as we move into this this
this situation where there's a shrinking
pi people who have tenure aren't parts
safe themselves because as soon as the
school goes into financial financial
exigency all bets are off they can they
can fire anybody they like they can
reconfigure anything that they need to
and I've seen a few schools that some of
my friends work at where they just go on
through that in the last couple of years
one school they just lost half their
philosophy faculty the you know half of
the department had to be shuffled out
and the ones who survived were the ones
who are you know either administrators
or you know teaching a class here and
there or they hit they were involved in
some sort of other programs so they were
most
a we're moving to a time when there
aren't any Gibbons when it comes to to
education for for teachers or for
students it's kind of sad to say but the
years where we can have tracks and you
can say well as so long as I get myself
on this track i'm going to be okay I
don't need to think about where I'm
going those yours are over that economy
is finished at least that's my
pessimistic cake no I think III think
you're absolutely right i mean you know
technology has driven well combination
of Technology and cultural changes
always drive big on oh I'm let's just
let's skip because he he um he wrote a
comment you want to read it sure uh
where is it it said okay I've got it's
under questions I met is he says I'm
always hope you got it ok yeah I meant
is all this is a good question is Oxford
and Cambridge the next Detroit what a
metaphor well education free services
not only make most educators the old
models unemployed is that not why we are
seeing a bubble intuition I think I
think I remarked to you that some of my
tenure you know tenure track and some
not even tenure track just you know have
full-time jobs they hear about a player
known they're like you've gone over to
the dark side cuz you're going to be
taking you're going to be taking food
out of our mouths you know and i'll be
like well you know first you could
actually do it yourself ah but then you
know does your institution and the way
it if it's it's currently configured
does it have some inherent right to
survive you know well um I'm just going
to deal with exactly with the question
um to not piss off more people um that
I'm already pissing off one is Oxford
and Cambridge for the next Detroit okay
is Oxford and Cambridge the next Detroit
no um yeah and here's the reason why
we're always going to have a subset of
people oxford and cambridge or great
institutions but they also are dominant
culturally because of the network effect
of sending people in positions of powers
the question is whether or not those
networks of powers really mean much
anymore to people who want to be
innovative to people who want to
generate new wealth and i would say well
no um they're wonderful places but all
souls is not going to produce the
innovation like they did on back in the
15th through seventeen hundreds if you
want to be the next James Cameron okay
then go to Harrow go to Eton go to
Oxford and then play that game if you
want to be the next Hillary Clinton or
Bill Clinton or Barack Obama then go to
Harvard go to Yale and then um you know
get yourself a nice you know Fulbright
or roads and then climb up the greasy
pole that way um but I don't think that
for innovation and for really producing
new work and new new new types of
knowledge and new products and new
services for Humanity to help human
beings um I don't think that's where the
action is well free edge services not
make the most educators of old models
unemployed it's not free services that
are going to make them unemployed it's
the fact that um I mean when was the
last time you went to a public
university in the States or in Europe
and they actually had student reviews of
the professor's okay you literally are
playing a game of your plane a dice game
you are gambling when you sign up for
that course in intro to philosophy where
you sign up to that course on drinking
Stein or physics or whatever and you
walk into that class you have no idea
whether that person can actually teach
um and that's a big problem that's
what's going to make them unemployable
I'll tell you though you know my
students they used ratemyprofessor
assiduity ax in that same they all
cannot go yeah i mean i'm not suppose or
something out there
you know that's what they're going to
use and it's smart for them to do so
because they're they're not walking in
blind no yeah mark it's not the markets
not transparent but there's a bias there
see we're going to do student reviews
but they're not going to be anonymous I
mean some of those reviews on rate my
professor are brutal okay yeah and and
and butts and that's the other connect
part of our I don't see I don't see a
bad part of that go ahead no a student
if if a faculty member is locate off I
could never be honest in the reviews
that I was giving my graduate professors
okay I'm sorry but there's something
called retribution and boy does it get
practiced in higher ed okay um so I
don't if you want in our in the system
of a play no i mean like look they're
not the gatekeepers the professors
aren't the gatekeepers to your future
career at a player know like they are at
a traditional institution i already so
we require if you have if you have a
problem with someone we require them I
mean give them if they've done a
horrible job in the class say so give
them some feedback on it's okay arm and
if you're the only one has given them
the poor feedback then maybe that's an
issue that you've got but it's going to
be perfectly transparent and perfectly
Erina who are the good professors in who
are the bad ones on the last question
you have I didn't see the last part on
the last part of the question was
well you know jakub is a follow-up but I
do want to say something about the
Detroit Medical own so let me put it
into the the states because I don't know
which schools i would use in England for
this so Harvard and Yale are not going
to become the next Detroit university of
notre dame is not going to become the
next Detroit uw-madison is not going to
become the next Detroit mutant do you
know what we're going to see a lot of
places that are in the middle tears and
the lower tiers especially become the
next Detroit and there's gonna be a lot
of CI integrated just not able to I mean
think about what happened with Detroit
it wasn't just one single you know
catastrophic fall it was a shrinking of
resources that then led to you know
fighting over you no shrinking pie and
shrinking more and shrinking more I
think that we're going to see quite a
few of the middle and lower to your
institutions of that that's going to
happen to them because it's already in
play for something I think you can
actually do that yeah I think you
disagree well i disagree i think on what
you need to do is you need to look at
which schools what is the percentage of
their budgets that are dependent upon
student loans okay and you look at that
you look at that figure because the
rates are not going to be as low as they
are for much longer oh ok and then when
that when when those rates change days
you sulfate the game is up okay and it's
that it's that chunk of change so it
might not be a smaller Institute's
so-called second or third-tier
institutions which have a smaller
percentage of the of their cash flow
depended upon student loans will make it
those who have a huge percentage aren't
going to make it we already see kind of
this point in California with government
subsidies I mean they're already cutting
back on higher Ed's so I would say this
i mean when the bond market fails okay
the Detroits are going to be a parent
all
all over and a lot of places that are
going to go under are the for-profits
who are dependent upon I mean I we made
a particular deliberate decision not to
get involved with federal student loans
okay because again you know that makes
perfect sense yeah because of that yeah
why would why would we become dependent
upon a system let's let's take be nuts
anyway yeah
yeah and then you put in a Cubs uh last
comment
yeah so he says hence the new brand
would be the educator and not the
institution for example i studied at
gregs youtube and that lasted from
Cambridge I don't see that I don't see
that happen I disagree I disagree um I
think that the I think that was a great
yes absolutely well it's not the brand I
mean if I'm gonna hire somebody I'm
gonna look at their you know when I hire
somebody I'm going to look at their
electronic portfolio okay their
portfolio feels that they have and I'm
going to look at who at the rankings of
their professors and I'm going to look
at who their professors were and I'm
gonna that's how I'm going to judge the
quality of an individual um and so it
becomes much more i think that the the
you know i mean you be nuts to hire
somebody who has a degree from Cambridge
just on the basis of that there's gonna
be a whole lot more discovery I mean you
know you look at transcript these days I
mean like a transcript from Harvard is I
mean I'm sorry not like what is it
seventy percent of the people get a's me
what is that telling me you know nothing
um why would I hire somebody from there
I mean it doesn't tell you all it says
is there was a sorting function the
person is fairly bright he knows how to
take he or she knows how to take sats
they played the correct game in high
school and they're in harvard and wow
they were in mass hall and they were
members of the porcelain club okay so i
know they know how to use the small you
know fork okay to the oyster fork and
they know how to you know do the do the
you know pick the right wine but coming
come on I mean reality is much more
complex yeah but do you think that with
this question you make a good case for
why the educator the professor the
instructor accounts but I can't imagine
a whole bunch of sort of just total free
agents out there outside of some sort of
institutional structure
um there will be some I think but a lot
of them are going to have to be within
some sort of institutional structure and
the institutional structure while
drawing on you know the quality of the
instructors reflecting that it is still
going to have to be sort of some sort of
imprimatur some sort of yeah this counts
for for for something I mean I know that
for myself I'm a good teacher I have a
lot of sort of name recognition now at
least in philosophy because of the
YouTube videos but I'm stronger if I'm
linked up with other people who have you
know some sort of similar connection and
we can say yeah we're we're offering
Murray University we r we actually
walked throwing things not just I'm
doing it's my whole show you know I
think for now yes but you know as as
time moves on and the ways of the ways
to look at arm skills and look at what
people are actually able to do that that
you know these networks these
assemblages are going to self-organize
and and they're going to become a parent
I mean how many people graduated with a
degree in philosophy from Cambridge 20
yeah okay you know I mean it's not like
4,000 yeah so you know those those
though that stuff fine you know they'll
keep the they'll keep their small market
um we're talking about education for
everybody not just an elite uh-huh and
and that's what we have to work on
creating not recreating Harvard and
Cambridge and Oxford create crits create
something for the information age for an
age when all of humanity has the ability
to access the greatest teachers and
sources of information for the first
time in history yeah and that's a
phenomenal thing so that's the last
question arm let's go let's do this this
is a really interesting one will this
trend not all not all so eventually
remove old ways the grading and get back
to
nation since educators might actually
have the capacity to do some more the
worst thing Ganga private reading you
know yup it is the ditch digging in
education um I think I think though that
that we now have the so we now have the
ability to record when people do things
we now have the ability to send to
create a a real true portfolio yeah this
this electronic portfolio that a player
knows spending a lot of time you know
conceptualizing and working on and we're
going to roll out on sooner rather than
later on and so I think that you know
when you go in to talk to someone
whether okay yourself to look at to take
a look at your skills that you have and
potentially the degrees that you're
building towards okay um or you take a
look at the skills that um you know an
employer is going to look at or how
somebody's going to find you on to
potentially employ you the ability to
pre to really look at the individuals
accomplishments versus their
institutional affiliation is increasing
and it increases through design and
through the net through information
technology and cloud computing okay so I
see teachers I see educators be coming
back to being you know coaches and
mentors and and practitioners but of
course in my opinion any teacher worth
their salt wants their students to
exceed their ability yeah I always used
to tell that to the seventh graders is
what's the difference between you and me
okay nothing I've just read more books
you're equally as intelligent as I am
probably more so okay so I've just read
more stuff and I probably have
accumulated more bad habits so the goal
of my teaching you a course in you know
Vermont history or in social science or
in system dynamics is to make it so that
you can do things that I haven't even
thought of and I think we're going to
get back to that and we're going to be
able to show that and I think we're
going to be able to empower a different
set of people who actually believe that
rather than the people who are really
good at playing the institutional game
I mean we have stripped down as much of
the nonsense as possible okay to do that
happens in institutions okay yeah nobody
has to get the course approved by a
department chair okay it has to have
good standards but we're not going to
you know we're not limiting you know
what someone's going to be able to teach
everybody can um you know you can decide
what courses you want to offer you've
got a global worldwide market arm to
potentially tap into arm total freedom
of academic freedom with one exception
you can't argue for genocide other than
that there's no group think you know I
want conservative liberal middle of the
road everything okay not just the things
that are you know supported by a tenured
on a tenure committee yeah so and all of
that that the the net in if it's used
properly can empower that arm oh also
this about creating one of the newer
ways of grading is to use it not so much
as sort of like the end certification
thing but to use it as formative
assessment over the course of the class
and it actually just call a spade a
spade it's a pain in the ass for
instructors because you have to do a lot
of I do this in my classes instead of
having you know two or three papers over
the course of the semester they write
every single week and I grade those
things every week because then they can
get some feedback and figure out how to
improve as they go through the course
rather than getting a all getting to the
end and finding out they don't really
know how to how to write the paper well
um and that's a newer way of grading so
I I think that and you know I don't Greg
Greg please that is an old way of
grading okay that is the old way that
was supposed to be done before we got
into large lecture halls and in MOOCs
and the notion that undergraduates sorry
the teaching
assistance we're going to teach 400
students in his space okay that used to
be the way it I mean that's the way it's
supposed to be I never saw off your grab
I I had a say I I mean if that's the old
way it like predates my college
experience yeah see I was very lucky I
mean I went to a small I guess you know
I went to a small that was my privilege
I went to a small liberal arts
institution on where the classes were
small yeah and I went you know in God
heresy upon heresy I did go to boarding
school okay and so um you know that was
uh um because I got in trouble a lot um
as a youngster but um you know I went
there in the courses were smaller and
that's the way education should be and
that's the way I think education can be
for everybody you know I get on if it's
designed properly and if there is a if
the financial model makes sense and now
everything is converging so that in
terms of the technology the business
practices where we can get back to that
we don't have to play the Taylor 'used
productivity nasty standardization game
that we've been playing in higher ed and
we can yeah and you know there's also
you know foucault that and power that
and all then we're not be [ __ ] with
with the bad decisions made by decades
of administrators as sort of the legacy
you know structuring how we how we get
hired and what we can teach what we can
what we can charge you know what you
know what interferes of making a living
all of that gets to sort of go away it's
kind of interesting I just thought of
this remember when when you know
southwest and jetblue you know were the
new air lines on the scene and everybody
was at all the old airlines and very
upset became any the pension obligations
that we have any the depth that we have
look at you know they're taking business
away from us I think a plan i was going
to be like that
doesn't have all the baggage of years
and years and years of bad decisions
well I don't see I don't think those
decisions were bad that were being made
in the past like with the you know I
don't think administrators were making
fat pulled up I hold on I don't think
the decisions that administrators were
making during you know the Golden Age of
higher read let's say from the 1920s
through the 19 29 1970 I would agree me
yeah III think that though that the
world has changed okay and so the
structures that were very strong and I
mean thank God we had a battle and we
had people willing to stick up for
academic freedom during the 1950s and
60s yes thank I think when I talk about
the legacy of bad decisions I'm talking
about more recent like the low-mass
generation or so like for example you
know basically keeping the the you know
the wages of the professor that was
still there as Professor it about the
same hiring tons of a adjuncts more and
more each year you know soaking more and
more money into administrator salaries
to try to compete with the other schools
building more buildings to try to
compete with the other schools expanding
the staff you know way beyond what was
actually needed but yeah I think all of
those could have been done perhaps
sometimes with good intentions they were
bad decisions and people people could
call them bad decisions at the time
people could look ahead and say look if
we're going to get ourselves into it
ignores about how gussied up the dorm
rooms are this is not going to be good
for for colleges overall but you know
they didn't do that and and the
college's part of the reason why they're
stuck in the current situation where
they're there you know they have to have
all these adjuncts because they'd blown
all the money that they had you know the
gravy days they had plenty of money to
do things with and they blew it on
buildings and getting into bidding wars
about how much to pay their their the
deans and Provost's and VPS but but
but if I didn't spend it on faculty
development they didn't spend it on
improving you know they improve
something things that I'm gracing well
there were no there were no market
signals for the administrators there
were none okay they had no feedbacks on
anything about about who I'm making a
bad decision okay remember I mean you
know in the early 90s all of the sort of
you know the if I remember correctly um
Middlebury Bates Colby and a bunch of
these you know sort of the smaller
prestigious schools they all got busted
for kind of if I remember correctly on I
think maybe even collusion in terms of
price fixing okay they didn't get
convicted okay but they all got kind of
like you know a little bit like oh yeah
you know cuz cuz hey they weren't they
were making we made sense they got
together and they were not armed they
were fixing prices so they didn't
compete on for a particular students um
you know on the financial aid thing now
it makes kind of there's a it makes
sense okay to do that a bit okay because
you want to make things accessible and
more efficient for everybody but the
fact is you know it was a really bad
decision there's there isn't any because
of the subsidized student loans those
feedback loops involving price and
involving what you're doing I mean
they're not there in fact I mean think
about it you've got for a lot of the top
tier schools that for some reason
everybody aspires to be okay everybody
wants to be the next you know um Yale or
you Chicago or whatever um since they
all aspire to it and they don't I mean
you know there's a smaller and smaller
pool of of those schools they want more
students to apply they all got into
chasing the US News and World Report
rankings arm and yeah and that problem
would have been solved if they hadn't
received as much subsidy from the
federal government in my opinion okay
arm it that those student loans okay
when you're getting a check
every month okay or every year and that
check is increasing no matter what you
do no matter what poor decisions you
make you're going to dig yourself deeper
and deeper and that's what's happened
and that's what's happened to our entire
country we dug ourselves deeper and
deeper into a hole you may want to take
ya Cubs last question we're gonna have
to close pretty soon and I appreciate
you staying on longer than the original
hour and a half I've just got to get the
next one isn't should we take this one
yeah I've just got to get 2x min okay
830 so we got time because I got to take
the kids okay have you considered that
in transmedia the future of a books
introduction would or could actually be
a course where it leads to commentary
transmedia project so a new book about
Aristotle might have a plural course as
the introduction that's an interesting
idea sounds great produce it my friend
and and produce we will offer it no it
sounds great I mean why not yeah um you
know I mean it used you know to go back
you know not too well to Plato or
Confucius aankhen kung fu Tzu I mean
these were texts did not everybody read
but everybody read out loud I mean the
Republic's a diet yeah most of the
Analects our dialogues the Mahabharat is
a dialogue the Quran is a dialogue you
read it you talk about it okay and so
what you're talking back what you're
talking about i mean we might think wow
this is a new innovation no it's
actually going back to the way arm
things used to be before we got stuck in
this sort of mass industrial production
thing so i guess that's the big secret
technology Wow yeah use technology to do
the stuff that we did in the past when
humans were humans and we weren't armed
what's that line in Fight Club arm you
know when you know you aren't your
things yeah things on you okay and i
think that was yeah that's awesome so
yeah so let's let's draw this to to a
close i'm going to give the last word as
I
to do every time to my guests what I
want to say is I'm very happy to have
this this session we covered a lot of
really interesting topics didn't of
course solve anything but we don't need
to we explored some some big issues and
education made some interesting
predictions which who knows maybe some
of them will be around when these things
come true or don't come true and I'm
very excited about this platform I think
you know that that's pretty much all i
have to say so you want to take us out
um i'd only say I appreciate the time
arm I you know this is it's been an
exciting couple of months to get a
planner out to the world and give it
over to arm the faculty to start
producing and to start creating this
change I mean um don't wait for someone
to come up with the answer you've got
we're already the answer what we have to
do is we just have to do it on and we
have to get out there and and be willing
to be very upfront about what we want
and to self-organize and so I always
tell you know I always talk with people
who apply um you know it'll apply to be
a faculty member want to work with us I
say you know don't ask for permission
ask for forgiveness okay so in other
words if you want to create an if you
want to create something a really
powerful program and you want to change
education check us out see whether we
can match your needs and then let's do
it and and let's not let's not wait um
because we are the people we've been
waiting for everything is set for a
major change in education and so let's
um let's start the revolution let's kick
it off you know one in the in the
immortal words of chuck d fight the
power arm and public enemy you know
Chuck D and flavor flav man and
and Terminator X there right fight the
power and so please apply and and um
thanks for the time well thank you for
coming on Robert and plural calm that I
would oh yeah why's everybody has been
watching this didn't go check it out
yeah but yes alright well put a note
down or email me with questions skip it
email me with a question that you might
have on skiff at a Plano calm and thanks
again Greg and we'll see you later
sounds good so that that wraps up this
this session